-The Justice Department
searched President Biden's home
over the weekend
and discovered a few more
classified items.
The news has
prompted Republicans,
who dismissed the much larger
cache of stolen documents
that Donald Trump refused
to return to criticize Biden.
And, on top of that,
Republican leaders,
like Kevin McCarthy,
are also refusing to take action
against serial liar
George Santos,
or, you know,
whatever his real name is.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You know, guys,
after the November midterms,
things were looking pretty good
for old Joe Biden.
He had the best
midterm performance
of a sitting president
in decades,
he'd scored a string
of major legislative victories,
gas prices were down,
inflation was slowing,
unemployment was low,
and he was hitting
his highest approval ratings
in at least a year.
In fact, one recent poll found
that Biden's net job approval
rating was now positive,
with 47% approval,
the 45% disapproval.
So, it was positive,
but like barely.
[ Laughter ]
That's the divided America
we live in now.
[ As Biden ]
I'm not saying I'm popular,
but 50% of Americans agree.
If you round up!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway, the point is,
Joe Biden was flying high,
although, I hesitate to say
he was flying,
given that we all know
how that goes.
[ Laughter and awws ]
I'm sorry, but we will never
stop using that clip!
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was
physically impossible
to trip up the stairs
that many times.
Did Kevin McCallister
"Home Alone" those stairs
in olive oil?
[ Laughter ]
Although, that shouldn't be
an excuse.
After the second fall,
even Marv would stop
[ Laughter ]
and reassess the situation.
So, Biden was riding high
and then, of course,
the classified documents
story happened,
and, now, his home
has been searched
by the Justice Department,
which turned up
even more classified items.
-ABC News has learned
authorities spent
nearly 13 hours on Friday
combing
through the president's
Wilmington, Delaware, home.
-The FBI discovered six
additional classified documents.
-He still had
classified documents
from his time in the Senate?!
[ Laughter ]
Biden's first year
in the Senate was 1973.
What were these classified
documents all about,
the government's top secret
eight-track technology?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] Check this out.
I swiped these coded messages
from the Pentagon.
"Don't fear the Reaper."
[ Laughter ]
What in --
What in God's name
could that mean?
[ Laughter ]
I have less trouble believing
that Biden had
classified documents
from his time as vice president.
He didn't exactly give off
the elder statesman vibe
during his eight years
with Obama.
I mean, does this look like
[ Laughter ]
the face of a guy
who is serious
about document security?
He looks like he's
about to roll a joint
with a piece of paper
marked top secret.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, it is so funny
to look back at that.
I definitely thought
that was the vibe of a dude
in his last job ever.
[ Laughter ]
Turns out --
Turns out he was interning.
[ Laughter ]
Also, investigators were
at Biden's home for 13 hours.
I have nothing to hide
in my apartment,
but if you told me someone
looked for 13 hours,
I would definitely think,
"Oh, [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
So, again, this isn't great
for Biden.
He shouldn't have had
those documents.
But the revelations have led
to some very silly punditry,
claiming Biden is, somehow,
in the same position
as Donald Trump.
-You heard from the Republicans.
They see a moment, Erica,
that, you know, certainly,
for the White House
and for President Biden,
who are claiming to have
the moral high ground,
they see that
that is not so anymore.
-Do you fear that,
because of that,
the current president
has kind of lost
the high ground on this notion
of classified information
being where it shouldn't be?
-It simply has taken away
the moral high ground
of this presidency.
-Okay, first of all, Biden can
still reach the high ground.
He just stumbles a bit
on the way there.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, again,
you need to be ready,
at any moment,
[ Laughter ]
for the stairs video.
I cannot stress this enough.
We're not going to stop.
Not just because it's funny
or because Biden is the most
powerful person in the world,
but because it is
scientifically fascinating.
[ Laughter ]
How do you keep tripping
while also moving upward?
[ Laughter ]
If you showed this video
to Isaac Newton,
he'd burn all his notebooks
and start over.
[ Laughter ]
But that was almost certainly
the last time
we will play that clip today.
[ Laughter ]
We've shown it twice.
If I know anything
about comedy...
[ Laughter ]
...it's the rule that twice is
more than enough!
[ Laughter ]
Now, as we've said before,
and we'll say again,
there's no equivalence
between Biden and Trump.
Yes, it's bad that they both
had classified documents,
but Trump consistently lied
about the documents he had;
told his staff to lie;
defied multiple requests
and a subpoena
for the documents;
moved the documents around;
and repeatedly changed the story
about why he had the documents,
in the first place.
Biden shouldn't have
had the documents,
but he never claimed
they were his
and he definitely never claimed
he had secretly declassified
them using his mind.
-You had said, on Truth Social,
a number of times,
you did declassify.
-I did declassify, yes.
-Okay. Is there a process?
What was your process
to declassify?
-It doesn't have to be
a process, as I understand it.
You know, there's different
people say different things,
but as I understand,
there doesn't have to be.
If you're the president
of the United States,
you can declassify just
by saying it's declassified,
even by thinking about it.
[ Laughter ]
-That is for sure
Donald Trump's dream,
[ Laughter ]
that thinking
about doing something
is the same
as actually doing it.
Donald, did you get Eric
a birthday present?
[ As Trump ]
I did something as good,
some might even say
even better --
I thought about it.
[ Laughter ]
I thought --
I thought
about a big motorcycle,
which I think Eric would love,
if that's the sort
of thing he's into.
I'll admit,
I do not talk to him much.
[ Laughter ]
A great big, loud motorcycle
with a bow on the handlebars.
So, I think
we can all agree that,
if I'm not Dad of the year,
I'm at least Top 5.
[ Laughter ]
Then last week, Trump changed
his tune, yet again,
and claimed he had taken
empty classified folders
as a memento
and that the feds,
who he called Gestapo
and "Trump Hating
Marxist Thugs" --
you know, like you do
when you're innocent --
[ Laughter ]
had possibly planted
classified documents
inside those empty folders.
-Quoting, now..
-Who takes home empty folders
as a cool keepsake?
[ Laughter ]
Also, what 76-year-old says
"'cool' keepsake"?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
You guys should come over later
and check out
my cool keepsakes, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to give anything
away, but here's a hint --
folders!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Yeah, no, I took -- I took all
the good stuff out.
[ Laughter ]
Just an empty folder.
You guys want pizza?
I got empty boxes.
[ Laughter ]
Here's the difference
between Biden and Trump --
they're like two guys who got
pulled over for erratic driving.
Biden immediately rolls
down the window,
hands over his license
and registration,
passes the breathalyzer,
and says,
"Sorry, officer,
but in my defense,
even stone cold sober,
I do this --"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that's
what we call the rule of threes!
[ Electronic voice ]
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
[ Heavy metal
guitar sting plays ]
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Trump, on the other hand,
is the guy
who refuses to pull over,
gets chased down,
goes over those one-way spikes
in a parking lot,
blows out his tire,
drives for another mile
[ Laughter ]
on sparking rims,
crashes into a duck pond,
gives cocaine and a gun
to a duck,
[ Laughter ]
and says if anyone asks,
"This is yours!"
Tries to swim away,
even though the pond
is shallow enough to stand;
gets to the other side,
[ Laughter ]
where the police are waiting
for him, and says,
"Oh, I didn't realize
I was living in Soviet Russia."
[ Laughter ]
Again, it's possible to hold
two thoughts in our heads
at once.
Biden shouldn't have had
those documents,
but also, comparing these
two situations is ludicrous,
which is why Republicans
suddenly find themselves
in the awkward position
of trying
to defend
their prior statements,
dismissing the Trump scandal,
while also hyperventilating
about the Biden documents.
And, in particular,
they seem to be focused
on one very specific aspect
of the Trump search.
-My concern is how there's
such a discrepancy
in how former President Trump
was treated --
by raiding Mar-A-Lago,
by getting the security cameras,
by taking pictures of documents
on the floor,
by going
through Melania's closet.
-There's no armed FBI raid
of Jill's closet,
the first lady's first closet,
as they did
with Melania Trump's closet.
-My point had been --
and remains --
the attorney general
had several steps
he could go through
before he's playing around
in Melania's closet.
-But it went --
-Are they going to rifle
through Jill Biden's closet,
like they did to Melania?
-They raided President Trump's
Mar-A-Lago home,
going through Melania's closet
and drawers
in a despicable manner.
-It's like they realize they
can't defend Trump anymore,
so they pivoted
to defending Melania.
"How can they do that
to this poor woman?
Isn't it bad enough
she's married to Donald Trump?"
[ Laughter ]
Now let's compare
the GOP's fevered reaction
over Biden's documents to their
much more cautious approach
to the many scandals
of a congressman
[ Laughing ]
supposedly name George Santos.
[ Laughter ]
As a reminder, Santos has lied
about virtually every aspect
of his life and résumé,
even down to his name
and his clothes.
-It seems like every day
we're learning something else
about George Santos' life
that simply isn't true.
Now, he's being accused
of stealing funds
from a homeless veteran's
dying dog
and lying about his mother
being a 9/11 survivor.
-There's a staggering amount
of fantastical tales
George Santos has told
through the years.
Saying he caught a severe
early case of COVID,
even though he was on TV
four days later,
or claiming to be
a "proud American Jew"
whose parents fled Hitler,
even though
he's actually Catholic
and has no Jewish ancestors,
as far as we can tell
from the records.
Said he owned
13 different properties,
when he's never been a landlord.
-This is the same George Santos
who said he worked
at Goldman Sachs,
which was a lie;
who said he worked at Citigroup,
which he didn't,
meaning that, too, was a lie.
It's the same George Santos
who lied
about the high school
he went to in New York
and the college he said
he graduated from.
He said it was Baruch College
and he got a degree
in economics and finance.
He didn't.
-More questions are being raised
about New York
Congressman George Santos,
including if that's even
his real name.
An ex-roommate
of the freshman congressman
had this to say --
-I've always known him
as Anthony Devolder.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I've never known him
as George Santos.
-Also allegedly stolen
by George,
according to these two men,
this Burberry scarf
[ Laughter and applause ]
that George wore
to a pro-Trump rally
in Washington, D.C.
-That's right,
he stole a Burberry scarf.
Even worse, he stole it from...
-Melania's closet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In fact,
not only did he wear
a stolen scarf,
he wore it
at a Stop the Steal rally
[ Laughter ]
on January 5th.
This guy's lies range
from his job to his education,
to his name,
to the clothes he wore.
We have no idea
who he really is.
He could be anyone.
-Yeah, Seth, he could be anyone.
-Wally, is that your real hair?
-Oh, what,
does it look different?
Sorry, I can't see anything
without my glasses.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Uh --
By the way, Seth, remind me
to give you back your scarf.
-Wally!
[ Laughter ]
Or should I say, George!
Or should I say, Anthony!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Santos returned
to New York this weekend,
where he was greeted
by reporters,
and he told them he couldn't
answer their questions
because the information
was classified.
-I'm focused on serving
the American people
and I'm super excited of it.
Yes, I have, plenty!
I just -- I went --
I went to D.C. last night
for a meeting
and I'm back here today.
I was here all week
and it's been fabulous
serving the people.
That's classified.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it's classified?
Well, good news --
classified now means
you can take it home and just
show it to whoever you want.
[ Laughter ]
So, Santos is refusing
to answer questions
about as many scandals
and, yet, the House speaker,
Kevin McCarthy,
is standing by him.
-Kevin McCarthy,
the House speaker,
indicated that he was not going
to take any action
on George Santos,
indicating, instead,
this would go through the
House ethics process
and then they will decide what
to do moving forward.
-The voters elected him
to serve.
If there is a concern
and he has to go
through the Ethics,
let him move through that.
-Are you going to take
any action
against him at this point?
Are any of these allegations
acceptable to you?
-What are the charges
against him?
-Well, I mean, he's --
-Is there a charge against him?
You know, in America today,
you're innocent
until proven guilty.
-[ As McCarthy ]
In America today, you're
innocent until proven guilty.
Now, has anyone seen
my Burberry scarf?
[ Laughter ]
Santos!
That's what happens when you
become the party of Trump --
you attract scammers
like Santos,
who seemed to have lied
about virtually everything,
from claiming he was a star
volleyball player
to claiming he worked
at Goldman Sachs,
to claiming he served as...
-President of the United States.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]